they're ridiculous yeah so yeah they're
great
oh hey there world didn't see you there
just having a couple brewskis with micro
here I see what you did this doesn't
this doesn't feel right
yeah really I'm sorry there you go God
how far you gonna go with this just so
we know as far as it takes anything you
got this job oh hey there world just
here with micro happened a couple of
brewskis we were talking about
profoundly disconnected you've partnered
up with caterpillar and you're working
on this that's part of it yes I mean
basically what happened was Dirty Jobs
finally ended and it took nine years for
that to happen and people started asking
questions like did you learn anything
and desperately wanting to answer in the
affirmative I said well yes sure and
then they said be more specific and I
said well from the places I went that
people I talked to the the recurring
theme from the show was that people with
dirty jobs by and large are happier than
you think and more prosperous than you
think more successful than people
realize and as a group seem to all talk
about this sense that they and the part
of the workforce that they're in are
disconnected from society at large in
the sense that there
there's lack of appreciation
understanding of what they do the best
jobs today in people's minds look very
different than the best jobs fifty years
ago and that's not necessarily a bad
thing
I don't think it's just that you can't
look at you can't look at blue and white
collar as as officers you have to look
at them as two sides of the same coin
and that just means you can't look at
service and manufacturing as opposites
you can't really look at anything as
opposite but that's what we do
well there's something about the blue
collar they're getting your hands dirty
that people still look fondly upon I
mean just taking a poll of the ladies in
the office today we're really excited to
see Mike Rowe coming on the show and
they're like I don't know what it is
about Mike Rowe but he likes to get his
hands dirty you probably experience that
a lot I mean they're just like look
there's no accounting for taste
oh but I think that I mean what's what's
attractive to me in people is is a mix
the truth is the the Handy gene is
rampant and my family they're all
fishermen farmers tradesmen but like all
really great trades they'll skip a
generation and it skipped me so I wanted
very much to be Bob Vila I wanted to
follow in my granddad's footsteps I
couldn't I mean I can hang drywall but
it's never quite straight you know I can
I can do all of it but I'm I'm not good
I relate to that I want to be that yeah
and the closest I can I'm more of like a
handyman
I'll just take that I mentioned that can
I get you another beer Mike no what
would you do with this on dirty jobs my
favorite moments are you know when you
can
I remember sexy chickens in Iowa I
remember you doing that squeezing the
poop at it and looking up their little
[ __ ] inside see we're a girl right
and you know doing this with a with the
very old Asian man who's an expert at it
and just just laughing and learning and
you're covered with you know dander and
and chicken crap flying through the air
and and I quoted Yates I remember a
woman who is proud and stiff went on
love intent cast her mansion by the
place of excrement for nothing can be
hold or so that has not been rented so
the idea of being able to essentially
all what's the word violate a barnyard
animal wild quoting of famous
professionally violate thank you because
it's not a hobby right no we were all
getting paid that's but what's
interesting are the things that appear
to be opposite but aren't even Iran you
know she wrote about the muddy boots
architect so it's not enough to
understand architectural II what you're
doing you need to be willing to walk
into the [ __ ] and actually get your
hands on it
separating those two things it's a shame
you know but that's what we've done and
that's where our disconnected lives oh
can i plug my sight yeah well please
know it's rude if I do you're doing I
wanted to do it you do it micro works is
that you can plug that if that's
like--you undo what's that
profoundly disconnected miles all we're
trying to do and I don't want overstate
it but all we're trying to do is
eliminate unemployment close the skills
gap address this whole currency
valuation thing address outsourcing and
manufacturing head-on and change the
face of the modern-day proletariat
easily the digital divide and we'd like
to get it wrapped up by Friday if that's
it is it
I think we can handle that so go to
profoundly disconnected comm micro is a
great guy thank you so much for hanging
out with us tonight miles long I'll
remember this yeah we'll always have the
memories so glad I have a porn name now
does anyone ever say cut in this
situation it just keeps on go